a stream of visitors at the national
museum in center open for Just Two Weeks
a chance for people to see some 2 000
looted artifacts that have been returned
to the collection
Riyadh al-fare is a researcher who
specializes in ancient yemeni history
we saw many things that we had never
seen before among them were pieces that
were recovered during 2006 2007 and also
in 2013 and 2020 pieces that had been
seized and documented by the Judiciary
are not on display
the museum opened first in 1971 and
holds thousands of relics from coins and
carvings to foliers from early qurans
some items are more than 2 000 years old
this is the throne used in ancient Yemen
it is decorated with Ibex's and
inscriptions of course it must have been
cushioned with something the
inscriptions are very precise with
important details the name of the king
and the era is also engraved here
authorities say the museum has remained
closed during the war to protect the
collections they also lack the budget to
keep it open
the main reason is lack of resources in
addition to the war imposed on us by the
saudi-led Coalition the Arrogant
American aggression on our country and
the bombardment in the vicinity of the
museum which caused many cracks and
fissures
in February the U.S agreed to return 77
stolen Antiquities to Yemen authorities
are hoping more people will be
interested in the displays so the museum
will generate enough money to reopen
permanently and preserve these artifacts
that offer a glimpse into Yemen's
ancient history
Al Jazeera